I'm Nastia Liukin, we're here at WOGA Gymnastics in Plano, Texas.
I'm so over the hill at 22.
I think it just makes it that much more of a challenge to prove to people that I still can be competing at that level.
For me in 2008,...
...I definitely achieved that lifelong dream of winning the all-around gold medal.
Now, it's like a whole different journey.
I really feel like I can help out the team on my two strongest events,...
...which are the bars and beam.
I definitely feel like my dad being my coach gave me a little bit of an advantage.
Not only did he compete at the Olympic games,...
...but he won two gold and two silver medals.
So it was like he knew exactly what it took.
We're both perfectionists: we both always want to win.
Second place is not gonna cut for me. Never did, never will.
I always say that we're Team Liukin.
It's like a triangle: there's three parts of it.
Team Liukin is the strongest in the world; number one.
And that's why it'll happen.
It was a team effort: Larry was the coach,...
...I was the supporter; kind of like a cheerleader, you know.
Coming back to 2012, it's different for me than it was in 2008.
I think about where I am today and what I need to get to to have another one of those golden moments in London.
All those people cheering at once just gives me goose bumps.
And you know, those are the moments that we kind of live for and that we train for it.
There's no greater feeling than that.